dienstagmittag im bundestag dieses foto
die kanzlerin die sich noch mal die
brille zurecht macht putzt neben dem
bundespräsidenten frank walter
steinmeier und das ungewöhnliche daran
sie sitzt halt nur noch auf der tribüne
seit heute erst die konstituierende
sitzung des bundestags rappelvoll da so
groß wie nie zuvor und die kanzlerin
nicht mehr auf der regierungsbank
sondern ab heute eben nur noch
geschäftsführend im amt da oben neben
rita süßmuth der früheren langjährigen
bundestagspräsidentin und eben dem
bundespräsidenten dass die neue rolle
von angela merkel bei uns im studio
jetzt bild meinung chef peter potthoff
sie froh dass der ganze aus ihrer sicht
jetzt misst vorbei ist oder wie es wie
es jetzt die rolle wie ist die
gefühlslage möglicherweise dieser
scheidenden kanzlerin ja also das sind
wirklich historische bilder kann man
wirklich will kann man kaum wegschauen
die mächtigste frau des landes die jetzt
als bundeskanzlerin seit 16 jahren
regiert plötzlich nur noch auf der
zuschauertribüne wie so ein gast der zum
ersten mal in den bundestag reinschaut
um sich das alles aus der entfernung
anzusehen ich glaube dass sie froh ist
dass es sich langsam dem ende zuneigt
aber sie weiß auch ganz genau dass es
noch nicht vorbei ist dieses jahr ist es
noch weniger vorbei als es vielleicht
noch vor vier oder vor acht jahren
vorbei gewesen wäre obwohl sie
geschäftsführend im amt es heißt es ja
dass sie immer noch verantwortlich ist
für die auch bewältigung der korona
pandemie und die zahlen steigen gerade
wieder die ganze debatte kommt ja wieder
hoch man weiß nicht wie diese neue
corona welle sich auswirken wird und sie
ist halt immer noch dafür verantwortlich
auch wenn sie heute noch auf der
zuschauer tribüne sitzt deswegen ich
glaube sie weiß zeigt sich dem ende zu
sie schaut vielleicht auch mal wie lange
sie noch durchhält als geschäftsführende
kanzlerin das hängt jetzt nicht nicht
mehr von ihr ab sondern von der ampel
koalition die wir die wollen olaf scholz
ja anfang dezember zum kanzler wählen
und dann wenn er wirklich anfang
dezember bundeskanzler wird und merkel
eben nicht mehr dann ist sehen nicht die
am längsten amtierende bundeskanzlerin
dafür müsste sie bis zum 19 dezember
durchhalten dann hätte sie helmut kohl
überholt corona dass jemand das hast du
gerade schon angesprochen auch im
bundestag kurz thema wie immer eröffnete
natürlich wolfgang schäuble die sitzung
wir schauen mal rein was er zum thema
corinna gesagt hat
zu beginn der pandemie haben wir ja
erlebt wie groß in einer
gefahrensituation das bedürfnis nach
klaren politischen vorgaben des wir
brauchten
wissenschaftlichen rat
doch der stand der virologie und der
medizin war damals noch recht unsicher
weil es eben ein neues phänomen war die
wissenschaftliche logik die nicht nur
auf konsens sondern gerade auf
antiquität zweifel und widerspruch
beruht geriet in ein spannungsverhältnis
zu den dringenden politischen
notwendigkeiten parlament und regierung
mussten handeln und wir mussten trotz
des unsicheren erkenntnis tanz und im
wissen um die vorläufigkeit
wissenschaftlicher forschung rasch
entscheidungen treffen und dabei
verschiedene disziplin hören die
soziologie die ökonomie psychologie und
pädagogik auch den ethikrat der
natürlich galt es die ethisch moralische
dimension genauso wie die
verfassungsrechtlichen aspekte unserer
maßnahmen mit zu bedenken
ja viele patov ganz nah schwerwiegende
setzte davon wolfgang schäuble heute in
seiner letzten rede übrigens als
bundestagspräsident er dann dieses amt
abgibt abgeben muss eine abrechnung im
grunde mit der korona politik vor allen
dingen im kanzleramt mit einer gewissen
wissenschafts gläubigkeit dort ganz
genau das war ein klassischer wolfgang
schäuble es waren relativ harte worte
auch wenn man es erstmal gar nicht so
ausfällt aber zwischen den zeilen
verbirgt sich wirklich ganz tief
greifende kritik an der krone politik er
sprach von den widersprüchen die es in
der wissenschaft gew sprach davon dass
man auf verschiedene disziplinen hören
musste und damit spricht er genau die
kritik an der bundeskanzlerin im
kanzleramt immer wieder gemacht wurde
dass man eben nicht auf
wissenschaftliche widersprüche
eingegangen ist sondern dass man gesagt
hat die wissenschaft fordert das und
jenes so wie es die leopoldina
beispielsweise im dezember 2020 macht
hat und der locker und dann verlängert
wurde die kanzlerin selbst hat immer
wieder gesagt die wissenschaft sagt uns
das und jenes und dass schäuble jetzt
das noch mal betont dass es verschiedene
meinungen gibt auch innerhalb der
wissenschaft ich glaube dass es bei der
kanzlerin angekommen und auch die
verschiedenen disziplinen auch das wurde
der kanzlerin vorgeworfen dass sie nur
auf virologen hört und auf ihre
modellierer aber dass sie nie auf
kinderärzte beispielsweise auch
pädagogen aus sozialwissenschaftler
gehört hat dass wolfgang schäuble das
als scheidender bundestagspräsident
jetzt noch einmal so erwähnt das ist
glaube ich durchaus als seitenhieb in
richtung kanzlerin zu verstehen ja sie
wird verstanden haben sagst du davon
auszugehen denn sie saß ja wie wir es
gesehen haben auf der tribüne hat auch
diese rede von dort aus erfolgt das sind
wirklich tolle bilder die uns davor
wenigen minuten eben erreicht haben aus
dem bundestag die kanzlerin die
scheidende regierung oben nur noch auf
der ersatzbank sozusagen und jetzt
rücken ganz viele junge
bundestagsabgeordnete rein in den
bundestag nahmen die man noch nicht
kennt junge gesichter vor allen dingen
bei fdp und grüne philippiak of zb die
frische grüne abgeordnete aus gera aus
thüringen piotta ganz genau die hat
heute direkt mit einem instagram posting
aufmerksam gemacht auf sich
und da sieht man sie mit maske wie sie
ein bändchen vor zeigt hier da sehen wir
sie im foto das bändchen das braucht man
heute als abgeordneter weil es ja corona
bestimmungen schwarz rot goldene party
bändchen ganz genau und dazu schreibt
sie gefühlt gestern noch als grüne
jugend gegen zu viele nationalflaggen
argumentiert jetzt musst du hier das
hässlichste festivalbändchen aller
zeiten tragen und da frage ich mich
schon das ist dann dem bändchen so
hässlich dass sind offenbar die
nationalfarben und also wirklich wie
patriotisch man eingestellt das ist ja
eigentlich privatsache ich finde das
gilt auch für abgeordnete nicht jeder
muss so die deutschen nationalflaggen
hier am sakko tragen aber dass man als
abgeordnete des bundestages auf dem
reichstag steht ja dem deutschen volke
dass man diese national schlagen als
hässlichste farben aller zeiten
bezeichnet denn nichts anderes meint sie
das verstehe ich nicht das finde ich
bedenklich
sie vertritt ja doch das ganze volk das
ganze land und dieses land hat nun mal
dieser staat hat sich nun mal eine
flagge verschrieben also und wenn ich
also wirklich hässlichste farben aller
zeiten also gibt fällt ja vielleicht
kann den diktatur ein die er ein
bisschen weniger missfällt warum warum
was stört sie an schwarz-rot-gold ich
glaube das wird noch zu klären sein